longtime fans of The Witcher video games
are sure to recognize an early game
character in the third season of The
Witcher on Netflix they'll also notice
that things go very differently for the
character this time around at the
beginning of the Witcher season 3
protagonist geralt of Rivia encounters A
peculiar refined mercenary who goes by
the moniker Professor unfortunately for
the bespectacled wannabe assassin the
meeting is as brief as it is violent as
geralt dispatches the professor after
cutting through his men with the
greatest of ease I am petunia
hmm
the professor's foray into the world of
Netflix's The Witcher is so Swift that
people who aren't familiar with the
games might wonder why the character is
so elaborately designed the reason is
simple the antagonist's appearance as a
massive Easter egg for fans who have
played the very first The Witcher game
from CD project red in 2007. the
professor makes multiple appearances in
The Game and his players can no doubt a
test he's a far bigger challenge for
geralt than his Netflix version proved
to be the ease with which Henry cavill's
geralt dispatches an enemy who gave his
video game version such trouble is a
sign that by the third season Netflix's
geralt is the legendary Witcher at the
height of his powers and could just be
the most powerful girl we've seen so far
that's not to say that the professor is
anywhere near the strongest antagonist
geralt has to carve his way through in
the games but the Assassin is
nevertheless a formidable challenge Whom
The Witcher faces more than once he's a
condescending snide man who isn't afraid
to rely on underhanded tactics like
wrist mounted crossbows and Powerful
protective spells the professor also
also shows very little fear while
fighting geralt and isn't shy to lecture
the protagonist about his views on the
subject of witchers You Were Meant to
slay monsters without making judgments
philosophizing or nursing doubts
you're ineffective apart from being a
brief nod at the people familiar with
the first Witcher game the Assassin's
presence in the Netflix show is also a
fun meta joke of sorts because the
professor is one of the two first major
bad guys geralt Encounters in his very
first game with the other being azer
Javed he can be viewed as something of a
starter villain here he's pitted against
a considerably stronger and more
experienced geralt and the power
imbalance between the two is not unlike
what would happen if a video game
character returned to the first area of
a game after maxing all their stats
thanks for dropping by Professor there's
another key reason why the girl from the
games may have had a tougher time with
the professor apart from the differences
in his sheer skill and Power in the
first Witcher game geralt is dealing
with far more than the usual
world-ending threats and man-eating
monstrosities he has also lost his
memory this geralt is more or less a
blank slate and still a long way away
from the dominant intimidating fighter
he once was or would become Again by the
time the third Witcher game rolled
around the live-action geralt on the
other hand might be struggling with his
emotions but his memory is fine sower is
fighting skills his knowledge of Science
and all the things that make him such a
formidable opponent this geralt also
meets the professor in a random muddy
backyard while the game versions of the
characters contend in situations where
the professor has an upper hand at one
point he leads an assault against the
witcher-based care Morin and in others
he's protected by powerful magic still
let's be honest even if the professor
had brought his full bag of tricks in
the Netflix show it's unlikely that he'd
last long against this driven
resourceful and tougher than ever geralt